Part of what makes the Marvel Cinematic Universe
fun is how plotlines pay off over
multiple movies. But that doesn't
mean every storyline gets a proper ending.
Here are some that completely disappeared.
At the end of "The Incredible Hulk,"
Tim Blake Nelson's Samuel Sterns is
coerced into giving Emil Blonsky a medical
procedure that turns him into The Abomination.
As Blonsky charges out of Sterns' office,
he sends the scientist flying into a wall,
and a small drop of Hulk's blood falls from a
nearby table onto a wound on Sterns' forehead.
The man's head begins to bubble and, just like
that, the origin story of Marvel Comics villain
The Leader is put into motion. The producers
of this project were hoping Sterns could
return in an "Incredible Hulk" sequel with
The Leader's green skin and enormous cranium.
However, "The Incredible Hulk" didn't light
the box office on fire, and there were also
rights issues regarding further solo "Hulk"
movies, leaving a reappearance by The Leader
in limbo. More than a decade after "The Incredible
Hulk," other characters from that Marvel Cinematic
Universe entry, such as General "Thunderbolt" Ross
and even The Abomination, have come back to play
a part in newer movies. But the origin story
of The Leader has never been followed up on,
and it doesn't appear to be something
that'll get expanded on anytime soon.
In "Thor: The Dark World," a comic relief
character got her own comic relief sidekick.
Darcy Lewis, Jane Foster's humorous intern from
the first "Thor" film, got an assistant to help
her lug things around in the form of Ian Boothby.
The two have a mildly conflict-ridden dynamic
throughout the adventure, before abruptly kissing
during the invasion of London by the Dark Elves.
Ian's role in the MCU was extremely short-lived.
He, like Jane and all of Thor's Earthbound
cohorts, did not return for "Thor: Ragnarok."
"Sorry to hear that Jane dumped you."
"She didn't dump me, you know. I
dumped her. It was a mutual dumping!"
In the years since, however, Jane Foster
has managed to land a comeback in "Thor:
Love and Thunder" while Darcy returned in
"WandaVision" as a full-fledged doctor.
Yet Darcy made no mention of Ian. Their
romance, and the character of Ian altogether,
was apparently just not meant to
last very long in this franchise.
In the middle of "Captain America: Civil War,"
Tony Stark drops a bombshell on Steve Rogers:
he and Pepper Potts are taking a break. After
the character was absent from "Avengers:
Age of Ultron" due to her duties to Stark
Industries, this confirmed that Stark was
officially single again, thanks in part to his
non-stop adventures with the Avengers. It was a
significant development that also helped explain
why Potts was suddenly M.I.A. from the franchise.
"Is Pepper here?"
"We're taking a break."
But this development was abruptly upended
in "Spider-Man: Homecoming," when Pepper
Potts not only reappeared but was
being intimate with Stark as if
nothing had ever happened. There was even a gag
about Stark popping the question to Potts in lieu
of introducing Spider-Man in his Iron Spider
outfit to members of the press. The sudden loss
of Potts in Stark's life never got referenced
in the following two "Avengers" movies either,
making this a strange unexplained detour in
the love life of two principal MCU figures.
In the wake of "The Avengers," "Thor: The
Dark World" finds scientist Erik Selvig
struggling to maintain a proper psychological
state. Having had Loki control his mind for
an extended period of time, Selvig is
now fit to bouts of strange behavior,
like wandering around Stonehenge naked.
He's even been locked up in a psych ward,
which Darcy and Ian must break him out of to
assist Thor in his quest to defeat the Dark Elves.
The lingering aftereffects of Selvig getting
his brain scrambled in "The Avengers" wouldn't
last forever, however. When Thor went to
recruit his help in "Age of Ultron," Selvig
was seen walking out of a college that
he teaches at. Not only had he returned
to his regular day job, but he seemed to have
fully recovered from his encounter with Loki.
At the end of "Iron Man 2," weapons manufacturer
Justin Hammer is arrested by police officers.
As this happens, he calls back to
Pepper Potts that it isn't over.
"I'm gonna be seeing you again, real soon."
Perhaps that was originally the plan. MCU films
don't just keep any villain alive and well,
after all. Keeping Hammer alive
and thirsting for vengeance
had to be thought of as a way
to set up future installments.
However, for whatever reason, Hammer has not
re-emerged in the MCU. "Iron Man 3" had no place
for Hammer, replacing him with Killian, while
other movies starring Tony Stark, like "Captain
America: Civil War," also found no room for him.
The most peculiar part of this is that Rockwell's
profile has increased substantially since "Iron
Man 2" came out. Having won a Best Supporting
Actor Academy Award and getting another Oscar
nomination in the same category, one would think
Marvel Studios would be scrambling to bring him
back. Instead, Rockwell's entire presence in this
franchise has been limited to "Iron Man 2" and a
tiny cameo in the short film "All Hail the King."
In "The Incredible Hulk," viewers
aren't just introduced to the Hulk.
They also get a first glimpse of the franchise's
version of the romance between Bruce Banner and
Betty Ross. This is a relationship complicated by
Banner watching out for his heart rate quickening,
out of fear of turning into the Hulk. This dynamic
was established as a crucial part of Banner's life
and was even used as a signifier that there may
be more of Banner in the Hulk than there appeared.
However, Betty has never resurfaced in the MCU
despite her father, General "Thunderbolt" Ross,
managing to re-emerge as a recurring
presence in recent entries in the saga.
The character hasn't even been referenced
again, either by her father or by Banner.
Instead, Banner took up a romance with
Black Widow in "Avengers: Age of Ultron,"
which seemed to close the book on this
initial love affair for the Hulk's alter-ego.
The only post-"Incredible Hulk" nod to the
character in the MCU was through the initial
codename for the Hulkbuster armor AI in "Age
of Ultron" being Veronica, a nod towards the
Archie Comics character of the same name
who had a rivalry with a lady named Betty.
"Captain America: The Winter
Soldier" ends with a genuinely
interesting beat. After faking
his death earlier in the film,
one would expect Fury to just return to his
regular day-to-day duties by the end of the
feature. Instead, Fury makes the conscious choice
to remain deceased to the general public. The
viewer even gets a glimpse at his headstone in a
Washington D.C. cemetery. As Fury walks off-screen
in "The Winter Soldier," the possibilities
for what he could be up to next are limitless.
Strangely, then, "Age of Ultron" brings things
right back to their original status quo. While
initially Fury is depicted as someone
who's been off the grid for a while,
he's eventually shown to be manning a Helicarrier
in his traditional leather garb to help Sokovian
civilians get to safety. Rather than a shadowy
individual believed to be dead by most,
Fury is once again a public
figure that everyone knows
is alive and well. It's a strange move that
undercuts the ending of "The Winter Soldier"
and all the narrative possibilities that
Fury remaining dead could have brought.
In the initial "Guardians of the Galaxy" movie,
Xandar is an important planet. It's where
four of the five titular superheroes meet up,
as well as home to the headquarters of the Nova
Corps organization, and the backdrop for Ronan
the Accuser's massive final battle to execute
his vengeance against the planet's occupants.
Given all that and the fact that it housed an
Infinity Stone at the end of "Guardians of the
Galaxy," fans might expect such a location
and its characters, including Nova Prime
and Rhomann Dey, to reappear throughout future
MCU adventures, particularly cosmic-based ones.
Instead, the planet hasn't reappeared at
all in subsequent films. The Nova Corps gets
name-dropped in "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2", while Xandar also gets mentioned in "Thor:
Ragnarok" and "Avengers: Infinity War."
That's the extent that this planet has
factored into the franchise post-"Guardians
of the Galaxy," with even its destruction by
Thanos happening entirely off-screen. Xandar
started as a seemingly important place,
but it's been largely brushed aside in the
mythology of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Starting with the show's second
season, Bobbi Morse was a critical
part of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D." and
its ever-expanding mythology. However,
she and her love interest Lance Hunter eventually
left "S.H.I.E.L.D." in the third season episode
"Parting Shot." In-universe, they were forced to
leave to keep Coulson and company safe. However,
beyond these fictitious confines, Morse's
sudden absence was done to allow herself
and Hunter to headline a spin-off
show entitled "Marvel's Most Wanted."
"They're not coming back. They've been disavowed."
"What're you talking about?"
"There were no good options."
However, those plans hit a snag when ABC opted to
pass on "Most Wanted," leaving the two characters
in a state of limbo. Though Hunter managed to
return in a guest appearance capacity in a later
episode of "S.H.I.E.L.D.," Morse remained
M.I.A. for the rest of the program's run.
Part of this appears to be due to scheduling
conflicts for actress Adrienne Palicki,
who eventually found a lead role on the
Fox sci-fi series "The Orville." However,
no official reason has ever been
given for her sudden departure.
Whatever caused the character's absence, a
hole was left in the "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
mythology that kept all storylines
related to Morse awkwardly unresolved.
For "Ant-Man and the Wasp," the two titular tiny
heroes faced off not against Thanos, or He Who
Remains, or Ultron, but rather Ghost, a woman who
can move through objects and constantly looks like
she's glitching in and out of reality. Ghost
turned out to be a morally complicated figure,
one who merely wanted to cure her condition, not
destroy the world. While she wasn't above doing
bad things, she was also somebody whose
life wasn't defined by acts of malice.
A scene at the end of "Ant-Man and the Wasp"
suggested that she and her surrogate father
figure Bill Foster would be sticking together for
whatever came next. But Ghost has ended up being
absent so far from the rest of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. Despite Ant-Man even
name-dropping her during the mid-credits scene of
"Ant-Man and the Wasp," Ghost has never appeared
in another MCU entry. It also doesn't look like
Ghost will get her storyline resolved in the
upcoming "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
either — there's been no news on Ghost star
Hannah John-Kamen getting cast in that film,
plus she's committed to starring in "Red Sonja."
In the middle of "Spider-Man: Homecoming," the
young webcrawler's inexperience with properly
handling criminals is made apparent through
the bungling of his attempt to stop a weapons
sale on a ferry. This transaction involves
the henchman of the film's primary villain,
Adrian Toomes, aka The Vulture, but it also
entails Mac Gargan a criminal who, in the comics,
is also known as the supervillain The Scorpion.
Here, Gargan is depicted as just a regular person,
albeit one with a scorpion tattoo on his
neck. He quickly vanishes in the chaos
of Spider-Man's botched attempt to stop the crime.
The mid-credits scene of "Homecoming,"
in which a battered and vengeful Gargan
confronts Toomes in prison and asks him if
he knows the secret identity of Spider-Man,
seemed to be setting up the idea of Scorpion
as a recurring threat to Spider-Man. However,
Gargan has made no further appearances
in either "Spider-Man: Far From Home"
or other Sony/Marvel productions like "Venom."
There's also been no word on him appearing in
future productions like "Spider-Man: No
Way Home," while a rumored presence in
the feature "Silver and Black" went nowhere
once that film got canned in pre-production.
While Gargan was useful in showcasing
Spidey's inexperience in "Homecoming,"
the seeming lack of interest in
further exploring the character
indicates his usefulness in the
MCU may have come to a close.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.